at carpenter the Cardinals infield are
joining us on the program Matt what are
you thinking when you're hearing this
stuff when you're on hold I mean that's
pretty amazing stuff there I'm not sure
what's running through my head when I
did something like that well we have our
Trager grill we have meat Friday and so
we're always cooking stuff so we just
had it we didn't have theme music and
that's why we have some people have
offered up their uh can you sing it all
yeah I mean I think I could sing but
only when nobody's listening yeah
I'm right there with you and we think we
sound really good when nobody's
listening it's when they start to listen
where you realize we're not any good
what is your walk-up zone well I've
actually got three and the three it's
Turnpike troubadours long hot summer day
Cody Jenks loud and heavy and the band
of heathens hurricane the true boat is
Jason Isbell is that the troubadours no
that's different but also as well okay
wait so how do they decide which walk-up
song do you have well I just grown tape
oh okay so you know each it bad is a
different song so they just kind of keep
the crowd on their feet keep them
guessing what's the worst walk-up song
you ever heard whether it's a teammate
or an opponent oh geez
you know what currently right now and I
hate to put them on blast but kolten
Wong has one of the worst ones going
right now i teammate the thought behind
it is great it's like that he's from
Hawaii it's kind of his native song but
the actual song will just make you want
to pull your hair out what is it
I don't even know what it's called it
sounds like something off the Little
Mermaid maybe it is but you know what
again I think it's a it's a great you
know it's a great thing for him and it's
great thing for Hawaii it's just it's
just not I guess if you're not some
Hawaii it's just tough to understand and
it might not be that intimidating as
well because you sort of want like you
know when Rivera came in it was Enter
Sandman like you knew like the game was
over here comes Mariano Rivera
you want something that really kind of
feels like it's got great got
intimidation attached to it a little bit
right and I think that's what it's
missing it's missing the intimidation
factor how do I introduce you as far as
the position goes it's a great question
I think currently you can say first base
if you ask me that
three months ago I might have been
tougher answer but I think that uh first
base is a good position to save
currently house you got hit the other
night right yeah dad didn't leave yep
didn't leave a mark it did I got a UH
you know a nice little Rawlings baseball
scene across top of line Japan but uh
you know no injury note no broken bones
so we live to play another day how do
you know if it's intentional or not I
think that you just have that feeling
you know like for example that
particular at that I mean I just you
know there's definitely no intention
there I mean this is a guy that he's got
a pretty good sinker that runs pretty
heavily on lefty on Lefty
he's trying to pitch in and it just got
away from him you know but you can tell
it's almost like I swear when you're in
the batter's box happen to me a few
times in my career you just can almost
tell as he's delivering the pitch of
their eyes and their sights are just in
a different spot when they're thrown at
you as opposed to when they're actually
trying to execute a pitch so it's pretty
obvious when you're in the box you just
get that feel wait explain that to me of
what do you see when you think they're
coming at you so you know you've got
your what I like to call them is your
visual elaine's
of where you're trying to hit the
baseball and when a pitcher you know arm
slot hits that Lane and you're tracking
whether it's going to be a ball or
strike when a guy is throwing at you it
goes into a completely different length
the lane that just instantly tells you
okay something's different here and then
that ball just comes bearing down in on
you and your ribcage or your head
wherever you wherever it's wherever it's
headed and it's just got a different
feel I mean you can just you can just
say
okay that was intentional what is that
feeling like right before you get hit it
depending on how hard the guys throwing
it can be a whole array of emotions
starting with panic - you know it's
obviously fear and then in the end then
it makes contact with you then look the
very next emotion as is pain who would
you not want it like nobody wants to get
hit but if I said I'm gonna let you pick
who hit you and who you don't want to
hit you who would be the two pitchers
please I think if I'm gonna not be hit
I'm gonna have to go with my teammate
your picks who's currently still on 105
I gotta catch this ball to first base
every now and then I mean like catching
I'm let alone get hit by and if I'm
gonna be hit I mean I would take any
knuckle baller and the game of baseball
currently if there is still one how hard
does Hix throw over to first base it's
it's like it's borderline you know
insane like it's boring like I had the
conversation with him about like we've
got to step it down a notch when you
don't either date though it borders on
borderline abusive there because I it
looks like you're just saying thank God
icon it thank God every time every time
I catch his throat I just first of all
look I got a look in the glove to make
sure it's a man that's just like you
know complete relief that I actually
caught it thought it didn't hit me you
know we got an out all those things go
through my head after the guy throws me
the ball and I had yeah every time he
gets a comebacker
you know they happen pretty often
because guys don't squirm up and as soon
as the ball is hit I will scream at the
top of my lungs easy and then he just it
like kind of settles him down and then
he still he throws it easy but it's 97
he's Matt Carpenter the Cardinals
infielder / first baseman and MVP
candidate if I would have told you back
in mid-may hey Matt I'm gonna talk to
you in August and you're gonna be one of
the top five MVP candidates in the
league your reaction would be with 33
home runs
uh yeah I shouldn't have I don't I'd be
lying if I said that I would think that
was a possibility you know I've said you
know too many people that uh you know
who I wasn't in April and in May I
didn't feel like was gonna be who I
would be at the end of the season you
know I never really lost the confidence
in myself to go out and produce I knew I
was healthy I know I was going to turn
the corner at some point but if I had
told you that or if anybody would have
told you that I'd be where I am at work
currently I don't think that I'd be
telling the truth if I'd have said I
would have guessed that you deserve the
MVP you know there's so many great
players in this league you know there's
this you know this big game of baseball
right now is full of young superstar
talent that can do it all you know just
complete five so guys and you know just
to be in a conversation with them I'm
very humbled by that and to be
completely Frank I'm not I'm just not
thinking about it you know we've got a
team that's making a late push here to
try to get another postseason in October
and that's my sole focus and you know
I'm gonna keep it that way
this making your own salsa thing has
gotten more headlines than you being an
MVP candidate man how did that come
about you know what it really has the
crazy thing was just kind of how it
started you know my dad brother and I
have been making salsa
for a long time probably my dad's been
making it ever since I was a kid and
I've enjoyed it then I started making it
probably seven eight years ago just on
my own and really how this thing kind of
blew up was one road trip teammate of
mine Adam Wainwright was on the DL and
he's a huge gardener and I told him that
if this was gonna be the last season I
was ever going to get to play with look
but I wanted him to show me the ropes of
gardening and when I went on the road
back in early May I came back from the
road trip and Adam Wainwright had came
over to my house playing in the garden
in the backyard teammate of the year you
know just huge teammate points
man I was obviously thrilled and started
making salsa out of my new garden in my
backyard and it just coincided with me
getting hot at the plate the team's
starting to play well and I've just been
producing mass amounts of salsa and
bringing it into the stadium every day
and it's kind of just we kind of just
ran with it
did they sell it at the stadium they do
not it's currently currently just for
player consumption oh okay
MBG is what I'm gonna give Adam
Wainwright most valuable gardener that's
a good call yeah MBG but you know are we
gonna start mass producing this are you
being serious about your salsa you know
what it's potentially a possibility you
know there's nothing set in stone yet
but I could see it being something that
could be available to the public or that
oh you have to especially now take
advantage of this is MVP caliber season
you know then they sell it at the
ballpark Big Papi made money with uh
with his hot sauce yeah yeah so I mean
it's definitely it's definitely a
possibility I'm not I'm not counting
anything out yet all right I'll leave
you with this the best pitcher you
homered off this year was who I'm gonna
have to go with Corey Kluber yeah he's
bad dude he's nasty yeah I think it's
kind of a stroke a lot good it was a
stroke of luck you know I mean the guys
just nasty I mean he threw a pistol like
I mean one of those home runs were you
surprised yourself
yeah and I definitely won oh well
congrats so far Matt's been a great year
and certainly keeping the Cardinals in
the thick of things and I'm sure your
name will be on the short list there of
MVP candidates and maybe you win it but
more importantly cash in on the salsa
there that could I could last you a
little while after the baseball season
is done Dan I appreciate it thanks for
having me on thank you Matt that's Matt
Carpenter Cardinals first baseman slash
infielder I think he's played third he's
played some second and first in the
National League at home runs good for
him good stuff
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]